I'm an actor and I'm a content creator I
do do food content mostly and that's why
I was like oh how do I split into other
things and
but also at the same time with my food
content how do I monetize you know brand
deals are very real I think the question
becomes are you business developing
enough to get the deals meaning if I'm
you I'm probably dming 50 people a day
Brands and just saying not hey we should
do business together just saying hey
look what you're doing or hey I'm a fan
like putting yourself on the radar
because the second they look over at
your account they're going to realize oh
there's potential to be something here
what I would call the Soft Cell say
hello but you need to be the aggressor
see what will come back to you when you
reach out to these Brands whether
they're cookware Brands whether they're
brands that you use in your food what
whatever they may be literally just
dming five Brands a day saying keep up
the good work I'm a fan of your product
like a little Karma A Little Romance